so how are you enjoying your christmas
holiday boys well that's when we're
recording this right yes
we are recording this during the
christmas holidays we've had our
christmas episodes but uh we are
enjoying our
christmas holidays right now even though
we're still technically working i took
two days off
and then i was like right a whole two
days back back to it then back to
youtube
i don't know i i really i even like
going one day without youtube i'm like
[ __ ] i want to do something yeah i want
to make something yeah i want to
entertain i want to be a clown i don't
know why you're a clown every day it's
alright
i think yeah there's probably some deep
insecurity that happened during my
childhood that
makes me strive to want to entertain i
don't know why but yeah i don't know it
was nice it was fun i i it's nice having
i think what the difference between like
a holiday that is everyone's holiday
yeah and one that you set for yourself
is that when it's like a like a national
holiday you're like well [ __ ] i have to
i guess
yeah yeah yeah yeah like obligated yeah
yeah but then sometimes you know you're
not your headspace isn't it you're like
man i kind of want to take a vacation
but like i don't want to
but then when if you do it yourself you
hype yourself up for it you're like i'm
taking this time off no one's going to
tell me what to do but on christmas
you're like [ __ ] i kind of want to like
i don't want to make a video i want to
[ __ ] around yeah i don't know what it is
about the christmas holidays i've
well i've always ended up working during
the christmas holidays because i've had
my yearly videos that
probably won't happen this year but
that's probably that's mostly what i'm
working on during the christmas holidays
um and then i've realized that
you know as youtubers you need to take a
[ __ ] break right yeah yeah and
it feels i don't know what it is but do
you ever get you know sometimes we take
breaks during the weekdays right
to us we don't like weekends don't
technically exist but i found that
taking breaks on the weekends feels a
lot
better than taking breaks in during the
weekdays because it just feels nice when
you know that
everyone else in the country and is on
the break as well you know
well except for most hand where yeah
yeah except in japan where christmas day
is just a regular workout
yeah yeah and also weekends are a
suggestion to stop working yeah
they're not enforced every holiday is a
suggestion
let's be honest i went up to uh
to the north of japan for about three or
four days to go see chris
yeah um and that was really nice there's
so much [ __ ] snow
did he make you drink shitty sacking uh
no he made me drink good suck
oh yeah and also that's an oxymoron for
connor yeah
also it was the first time ever i did
like a proper japanese christmas aka
kfc how was it it's just kfc
this is exactly what i thought it's just
chicken like it's
it's just like a triptych although it
was kind of weird because
chris had to schedule it like or book it
like two two or three weeks in advance
right and it's also weird it's not just
like a
you not only have to book it but you
have to book like a day in time to go
and pick it off yeah yeah
as well so it's like not only do you
have to come in on debt on a certain day
to a certain store but it's like come
between a 2 to 3 p.m time bracket
right and this and we went there and
there was just like a group of about
maybe like five or six families just
lining up to get their christmas chicken
from the colonel
and i would rather die than line up for
a case yeah
and i mean you know it was like what we
got like a full bucket of like just a
bunch of chicken wings
as as you do but also at the bottom of
the bucket there was like this
kind of christmas cake or like christmas
pudding right
i don't know because i don't think
anyone had a slice of it but it was at
the bottom of the thing we're like oh
that's
a little weird that it's just been
sitting underneath this like greasy
greasy [ __ ] chicken that's no way
you'd want to put a cake
no it was the last thing we were
expecting at the bottom of the bucket to
be fair
and uh it was like 5 000 yen for it and
it could feed maybe about
three or four people you paid 50 bucks
for kfc
on christmas yeah oh my god i mean i did
it
you could have had a nice roast dinner
for that oh no we ordered all the food
as well okay good but we were like
just because it was the first time for
all of us we've never had a japanese
christmas before so like you know what
[ __ ] it let's do it
and uh i wouldn't do it again to be
honest it's just it's just kfc isn't it
i just
go wrong because the thing is like this
is i think the fourth year that i've
been in
asia celebrating christmas and i gotta
say i you don't
really understand the entire the entire
like height behind this
uh the the christmas spirit you know
yeah i thought that was just like uh i
thought that was just my [ __ ] meme
it's just a marketing point yeah yeah
yeah i didn't understand that until i
started spending christmas
outside of you know where you know
countries that normally celebrate
christmas
and you know you can do a lot of things
to make it feel christmassy but having
spent a few christmas christmases in
asia
i kind of miss that christmas spirit
because there's there's a few things you
know
you can put on the christmas songs and
you can do whatever you know put up the
tree
but there's just something missing i
can't put my finger on it but it just
doesn't feel fully christmasy i think it
just has to do with the fact that at
least in japan christmas is not
a family thing yes it's like a romantic
thing
yeah and also everyone's working so it's
like yeah yeah like i got a delivery
on like as we were having our roast
dinner and it was like the least
it was like the immersion breaking
christmas right a moment
yeah yeah i had an amazon package and i
was like this is not christmas that's
the door on your red hat
like i i refuse to have this wine in
hand yeah
christmas simulation over it was like
that rick and morty episode where you're
just trapped in an ultimate like
like this this like reality yeah is it
like to me
christmas is like going back and
reluctantly having to talk to family
members about like
oh i do youtube you know this is what i
yeah naked online
yeah yes i make this much per year thank
you uncle for asking me for the seventh
time
you're investing right in a pension
right yes yes i am
no i don't know yeah i don't know it
felt it felt odd because i feel like
normally
i didn't i didn't appreciate christmas
that much because i didn't realize it
was a really good way of like
in my head at least i don't know if this
is because i've been this is how i
taught
it was like this is the end of the year
yeah now go and restart it
and then build up to all of this again
because it was it's not just christmas
it's that period between christmas
christmas and new year's
yeah that is just like the blank period
we don't do anything where it's just
like what rules
what what are the rules nobody knows
what's going on are the buses running i
don't know are the trains running
our shops open it's [ __ ] anarchy and
i love that period because it's
google how long can i have leftovers for
how many christmas dinners yeah that's
that was like
living in england that was like one of
my favorite parts of the year
it was just it was just as you said like
the reset of the year it was like the
entire
entire society was just kind of goes
into cooldown right yeah yeah exactly
right whereas here it's like
businesses business usually like
supermarkets and convenience stores are
open
literally 24 7. even on new year's day
my mom won't shut up about kfc christmas
to me she's fascinated by it she's like
i heard they have kfc for christmas is
it true and i'm like yes they do mom
it's like wow how crazy is that and i'm
like yeah it's kind of weird
it's too fair it is bizarre yeah it is
weird it's like you know
just all the things that japan has no
interest in from like the west right
yeah we bring our finest things are like
no no none of that none of that
and then suddenly the colonel rocks up
and he's like listen how about let me
pitch you this
y'all like greece
me take this absolutely nothing to do
with christmas food and somehow make it
christmas food
who did like oh my god like how do they
pull this off like i'm sure someone
knows the history behind it but like to
me even if you explained to me how it
was done
the kfc marketing department did this i
mean i explained it to you last time
right but even then it
still doesn't make sense to me i
researched it and it doesn't make sense
it was like the marketing heist of the
century god